my name is Barry Allen and I'm an
innocent man I'm being framed for
something that I didn't do
he stood among us a wolf in sheep's
clothing you're gonna plant evidence
this is the right thing to do Ralph just
open the door I'll do the rest if I
testify I have to lie I've become
exactly who they think I am
then don't lie tell everyone you're the
flash if everyone knew my secret we
would never be able to stop running
you guys ready I was more already great
let's suit up when you said suit up you
meant like right now yes now we've been
suiting up for 20 minutes okay
[Music]
everybody's surprise surprise all kinds
of new footage dropping for the flash
everything else so be sure to subscribe
if you're just finding me for the first
time I'll do flash ring giveaway stuff
at the end of this too but there's some
funny stuff in this and then there's
some really serious stuff because of the
trial of the flash legitimately serious
thing going on now we know how team
flash initially plans to beat the
thinker fight fire with fire you plan
evidence will plant evidence but I think
it's pretty safe to say that they're not
gonna turn Jo into a hardened criminal
after trying to get Ralf Dib knee to
stop being such a douchebag like the
whole thing that Barry got him kicked
off the force for was planting evidence
in Jo is literally doing it again here a
woman named Judy Giblin was stabbed to
death her husband Reagan was the prime
suspect but there was no evidence
nothing to tie him to the crime scene
and then Dib knee miraculously found a
knife with the husband's fingerprints
case closed
timmy was a hero I don't know maybe
because my mom was stabbed I wanted to
be sure so I analyzed the knife the SERR
ations on the blade did not match the
wound on the back so Tiffany implanted
the knife yeah and then he lied about it
under oath so remember one of the future
episode titles for the rest of the
season is called the elongated Knight
Rises like The Dark Knight Rises
this little subplot here with Joe and
him sounds like it's just gonna be more
of him learning to be a superhero so
there's a big question about the
timeline because they took him into
custody he be in county lockup before he
goes to trial before they send him to
iron Heights prison so prison is like
the super serious part of this like you
really only go there once you're
convicted for a crime normally he would
just sit inside the police stations
holding cell while he's waiting for
trial but they might change that a
little bit for the TV show but if he's
out on the sidewalk here in his flash
costume it means at some point he breaks
the law so that he can go save someone
so maybe they're doing a version of that
for all the storylines like oh I have to
break the law in order to do the right
thing I have to do the wrong thing to do
the right thing so that would definitely
sync up with Joe breaking the law by
planting evidence in order to get barry
off but bringing it back around to a
elongated man at the beginning of the
season if you know you flash back four
or five years if it was so important to
Barry's morals that you not do the wrong
thing even if it led to something really
good I think we can assume that they're
going to have a moment in the episode
where they're like oh we have to do this
the right way aboveboard otherwise we're
no better than the criminals the real
question is is how long is the trial
going to go on and how are they going to
beat it because what might end up
happening is is they'll just find some
way to prove that the knife was planted
or there'll be a mistrial that's
declared and it'll be postponed but they
might not completely resolve things even
if they get him off temporarily like
even if they prove the evidence was
planted I don't think that they're going
to prove that the thinker himself had
something to do with it because things
like that usually happened before the
big reveals like oh my god hunter
zolomon is zoom or savat are is evil
berry and then like a couple episodes
after that you have your finale right
before the big final battle like for
most of the back half of the season the
villain still has the upper hand
so I don't think you know whatever they
do to beat this it's gonna have anything
to do with throwing the thinker under
the bus but remember that video I posted
last night about that mystery girl at
Barry's wedding she's coming back soon
she could have something to do with the
next couple of episodes but we talked
about the episode titles in the two-part
episode that they filmed before they
went on break for Christmas so if you
want to go back and read about this in
the comics they're doing a lot of Easter
eggs but the circumstances of the trial
and the people that are involved the
villain that's involved is very
different it was a reverse-flash thing
in the comics and it was right before
crisis on Infinite Earths so it'll be
fun to see what they T up for the rest
of the season because remember the stuff
that happens during episode 10 we'll set
up the things that they'll pay off later
this season and this is the back half
which means it's really mythology heavy
so it's gonna get crazier and crazier
faster and faster so if you weren't
really happy with the first half of the
season the second half of the season is
probably gonna be more your speed to
make as many flash puns as possible a
lot of you've also been asking about
Goldberg coming to the show because it
hasn't been revealed exactly who he's
playing but he did say himself that the
reason why he wanted to come on the
flash is because his children were such
big fans of the show that
the new way you get those bigger actors
but we have Cody Rhodes on arrow who's a
character in the arrow verse now we had
edge who played atom smasher back during
season two probably closer to what
you'll see from the Goldberg character
whoever he ends up playing he'll be a
metahuman and he's probably going to
wind up being one of the bus metas but
here's the thing - Barry's getting ready
to go to prison remember all of the bus
metas that have been locked up so far
are in the same wing of iron Heights so
he might wind up being locked up with
those people and we might get to see
what's going on with this creepy looking
warden who's actually the warden from
the comics if you've been reading the
recent flash comics they've had this arc
where Barry is working at iron Heights
prison so he becomes a much bigger
character so we'll see where they take
that but just remember we haven't really
checked in with the bus metas in a while
so good luck gentlemen
Thanks central city's about to have its
hands full
[Music]
thank you for letting us see the
prisoner warden wolf my pleasure
did you get what you needed do you think
so well not to worry the so-called
Kilgore isn't going anywhere
what's a good care of
[Music]
but what's gonna happen next is they
just drop some new Black Panther footage
so I'll do a video for that I'm still
working on a black mirror video I wasn't
expecting all this new footage to drop
so I'll just try to get that stuff out
as fast as possible there's also a
Slenderman trailer that's supposed to
drop soon so I'll do a video for that
there's actually a bunch of stuff coming
like it's the beginning of the year so
everybody's like hell yeah let's dump
all our footage there's a new brand of
that flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and just
share the video using any of these
YouTube tools on the watch page
congratulations to the winner from my
last video Sheehan please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
mystery girl coming back to the TV show
this season and click here for brand new
black panther thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight